كما اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه رصد تعزيزات
روسيه اضافيه عبر القرم الى البحر الاسود
ورصد ايضا تحركات قتاليه ل 15 سفينه
الجنوب الاوكرانيه نتاليا هومي نيورك قالت
ان الجيش الاوكراني يواصلوا استنزاف
القوات الروسيه على طول الجبهات الجنوبيه
لا سيما في خلصون واذا بوجيا
على القوه الروسيه جنوبيه البلاد
يوصل الروس في البحر الاسود ارسال مزيد من
التعزيزات والقطع البحريه المحمله
بالصواريخ كليبر مجنحه من نوع كروز
لاطلاقها في اي لحظه لكن دفاعاتنا متاهبه
وفي حاله استعداد دائم ويوصل الجيش
الاوكراني يستنزاف العدو في الجنوب وتدمير
مستودعات الذخيره واماكن انتشار قوته
بضربات دقيقه استنزاف العدو في خرسون
وزباروجيا هو جزء من التحضير لهجوم مضاد
قادم على كامل المناطق المحتله في الجنوب